مع اشتداد المعارك في بخموت ومع تزايد
الروايات الروسيه باقتراب السيطره على هذه
المدينه يبقى السؤال ان كانت هذه السيطره
لو تمت ستسمح لموسكو وتجعلها متفوقه
استراتيجيا البنتا يقلل من هذه الخطوه
فبحسب وزير الدفاع لويد اوستن فان فوزا
روسيا في بخموت المدينه المهجوره من اهلها
بنسبه 90% له قيمه رمزيه اكثر منها
عملياتيه اوستن اكد انه لا يستطيع التنبؤ
بموعد انسحاب القوات الاوكرانيه من باخموت
لكنه اكد ان سقوطها لا يعني ابدا ولا يعني
بالضروره ان الروس غيروا مسار هذه المعركه
جاء التقدم في ثمن باهض بالنسبه لروسيا
وايضا اوكرانيا بعد سقوط الاف الجنود من
الطرفين وايضا تدمير العديد من المعدات
العسكريه رغم ذلك تستمر اوكرانيا بالتمسك
بالمدينه حيث امر رئيسها امر الجيش بارسال
تعزيزات للدفاع عن المدينه نافيا وجود
خلافات داخليا مع قاده جيشه مراقبون يرون
انه اذا ما استولت روسيا على المدينه
فانها لن تجد تحت ايديها سوى الانقاض حيث
ان البلده لم تعد تضم الا القليل من البنى
التحتيه الصالحه